Aaron Sampson you played a ton of Call
of Duty mana where for multiplayer only
and it seems like it's a fundamental
change for the franchise based on the
footage I saw that you recorded but
having played hours of it is that true
yeah this feels like Call of Duty is all
grown up it's not Arkady it's just a
complete teardown of the franchise and
they they put a new engine in the and
then they just built it back up around
the skeleton of what Call of Duty is
there's plenty of things in this that
are still familiar like you'll still
recognize killstreaks instead of course
score straights this time around and
you'll recognize a lot of the perks but
everything else feels different so the
guns are just completely redesigned and
the sound design around these guns is
just incredible we're sort of going into
battlefield territory now without
frostbite handle sounder and we're also
going into that territory with really
unique stuff like night fighting maps
and big team battle maps we got to play
at 20 V 20 I was rolling around in a
tank and a Call of Duty game which is
something I've never done before
sure and it just feels like they've
rethought it and they've examined it and
tried to make it as different as
possible so the arcade enos is very much
out and there's just a lot more posting
up building load outs you know going
through your toolbox per mode and I
really like it you mentioned big team
battles that's one of the things that
you kept emphasizing when we're asking
you what you saw there can you break
down what that is I know you said 20 to
20 Dement elite change how you play Call
of Duty is it a nice merger of the new
mechanics and you know bigger Maps and
what were used to in terms of you know
call duty firefights yeah so we played
10 V 10 and 20 V 20 and one of our
editors Phil he did an interview where
they hinted at maybe they could even go
up to a hundred oh well they haven't
talked about anything like blackout so I
think we think they were actually
talking about you know maybe even a 50 v
50 which is again like where we're now
heading into other games territories
which is really cool but the way that
this game is built and the big team
battle mode they work really well and
you know the weirdest thing was is that
in in the large modes it felt the very
call of duty because there were so many
people calling in their kill streaks at
an easier time like it almost felt more
Call of Duty then the smaller Maps did
be just because of the cadence of the
rounds the other really cool aspect is a
large battles is they really bringing to
play how unique their weapon systems are
now so you can build loadouts on a gun
bench and these loadouts
let you change weapons but every
attachment has a plus or a minus
so like something that's more
controllable might make you slower or
might make you aim slower and you can
screw up a gun build for the first time
in a while I can't remember the last
time you could just build a bad gun in
Call of Duty sure which is really fun
yeah um and then you know customizing
your your kill streaks for a larger map
matters so radar is personal in this
this version of the game there is a 18
radar kill streak but the vast majority
of radar is just on your character and
the radar map isn't even up most of the
time so in the big maps it was more
important to try and figure out where
people were but unlike previous Call of
Duty's the the mini-map and the radar
were just way less important in every
other mode
so like typically called duty games even
though they're all made by different
Studios they feel like they're
fundamentally like building off of each
other yeah this one from the footage
I've seen seems like such a dramatic
departure does it feel like they're
still taking elements from like black
ops 4 I mean that games like incredibly
Arkady and it's got like you know hero
shooter elements and yeah black ops 4
did some really interesting things that
I think the colony community had mixed
reactions to right operators were kind
of controversial I think operator has
brought in a larger audience of people
who loved hero shooters but there were
also a lot of people who just didn't
want to have to deal with barbed wire in
a room yeah so this game is more like
that in the sense of the gadgets so and
also maybe like a little bit of Rainbow
six siege so there are barricades and
this game is way more focused around
choke points on the map so instead of
three lanes there are buildings and you
have to hold those buildings so in that
sense that fortification aspect of it
and sort of the power play aspect of
those buildings it's a little bit more
like black ops and a little bit more
like a game like Rainbow six siege
however they don't seem to want to
repeat the operators so there are
cosmetic operators in this game and they
have voice lines and they have
apparently unique executions but they're
not gadget based
okay so they're kind of going back to
like older modern warfare where it's
more you're building your own personal
class essentially yeah and that's really
cool
another there's so many like nifty
little touches to this game
where they thought about it so if you
get killed a bunch of times by somebody
there's just a button you can press to
copy their loadout so you can instantly
figure out what it was that they they
killed you with and how they kid it out
it's like a really good learning tool we
play call of duty
year in and year out so we get to see
the I guess incremental changes from
from one game to another now you know
the big thing that I was talking about
you're talking about is the fundamental
changes how this kind of deconstructs
what we know Call of Duty as in the
modern sense but the moments mode action
like what does that feel like for you
who plays call duty every year so what
developers said and that's a great
question what they said was they're
trying to accommodate a bunch of
different playstyles being somebody who
does like to post up I found a lot more
of that in this game so so many more
objectives where objectives were there
actually is a sticky sticky system where
you can mount a weapon on something that
I used to a certain degree but so much
more of my loadout to were about hosting
up and the game was so much more
accommodating to that because gunplay
was it was slower and it was less
controllable by a wide margin yeah like
a lot of the guns and the guns are based
on calibers so you know SMGs are a
little bit easier to control but they
also felt way less powerful and like
LMGs are more powerful have more bullet
penetration which is in previous games
but they jump around so much more now
yeah and it's kind of up to you as a
player to fix your your loadout in order
to bring that gun under control if you
want to or turn it into like a tap fire
weapon sure so yeah like particularly on
games a game modes like domination there
was so much more posting up and
controlling
areas with slower movement there's also
now a whole new door system so there's
closed doors on the map and they can be
blown open they can be run and slid
through but if you do that it's super
loud there's like a big clang
and everybody knows you just enter in a
building or you can just kind of quietly
open the door
sure and go through so they've changed a
lot of these systems - it feels like to
slow the game down fair warning though
and you know when people get their hands
on the game they said they want to
accommodate different playstyles so you
might end up with the jumpy slighty
shotgun [ __ ] yeah that was a nice
like good about how much more subtle the
customization is yeah how you know you
can accommodate different playstyle so
I'm looking at the footage and I'm
trying to think if you know someone can
play this like they have played other
colonies where they're jumping jumping
and mantling to other buildings quick
80s Bam Bam Bam will turn around the
other way like 360 no-scope
someone else I don't know like it
doesn't look like this is that game but
it seems like maybe there will be a way
to but you have to think about how to
create your character to be that way it
also sounds like it might not be
suitable for every situation I'm hoping
quickscoping is gone some people
mentioned they might have figured out a
way to do it but it's so like you bring
up your scripts so slowly and I don't
think you can do it yeah but we did
there's we had a couple of moments that
were like oh this is old Call of Duty
like we spawn on a map we ran up and
just the grenade came over the wall from
their spawn and just all three of us
died instantly you know it's like yep
that person got the timing down this is
all Call of Duty yes I'm old school call
duty cheese right there right so you use
you see like old Call of Duty sure like
the fair it's just you have to do more
thinking to get to good okay all right
and I don't know again like I feel like
somebody at some point is gonna figure
out the old Call of Duty loadout and
they're gonna like that worries me like
I'm worried somebody I'm worried that
like the slower more methodical guys are
just gonna get overtaken again by
shotguns sliding McNew
and we did get rolled we did get
killstreak rolled in the big team battle
mode one time where we were just getting
dominated and it was like you know
classic like air strike air strike air
strike a-10 spawn camp done so it can
happen it's just less common sure do you
think like the realistic presentation
might discourage that because like
that's the whole thing with this Call of
Duty is like it's more realistic and you
look at like the level of detail and the
animations like the weapons way they're
clearly going for like a more realistic
feel that just makes it naturally I feel
like maybe your brain will naturally
like want to play it more like
tactically and slower because it looks
like that kind of game I think that's
how we were all playing it I mean that's
right on that's how we were all playing
it in this event because it looked that
way right but I but if you can still
play Haidee he's gonna do it I wasn't
early like I went to the first Rainbow
six siege demos and they also started
like that and ripe evolved into Counter
Strike where people didn't use the
gadgets and jump their windows so I
don't know what's gonna happen once the
public gets their hands on this game but
it initially feels like you should play
it more slowly I will say there's some
things that I've learned for a long time
like just when you're running in this
game your your gun drifts away from your
head to kind of indicate how long it'll
take for the gun to snap back up and
that means when you run you're at a
disadvantage like if you run around a
corner
the person that is not running has a
faster has a faster time to get their
scope up so that should discourage that
type of play style all right I'm sold on
Call of Duty you know being
fundamentally different from what it's
been in recent years my last question
would be though is that for those who
play this game every year is this too
dramatic of a shift for them in your
eyes that's a really interesting
question I think this game is maybe for
relapsed college any players you've
drifted off to other games fans of
modern warfare who just felt like
ecology you got to say me after that and
want to come back to it if you just want
to run into a room and throw a nade and
shoot everybody you might be able to do
that but I don't know if that crowd is
gonna be like that crowd wasn't happy
with operators because operators could
do things to stop them so it's a real
crapshoot as to whether the core Call of
Duty crowd wants a more realistic sim
style shooter but I think they'll
successfully pull in people from a lot
of other games to come and try Call of
Duty again that seems like what they're
going for
[Music]